hi everyone welcome to the final day of
the week of our data science journey by
simply learn on day six we learned about
deep learning for data science today
that is on day seven we are going to
focus on the top data science interview
questions that will help you crack a
data science interview now that you have
already learned all the important data
science skills in the past six days
now it is time for you to put your
knowledge to the test and check whether
you are able to answer critical
interview questions on machine learning
deep learning and data science Concepts
so let's begin this video will probably
help you when you're attending
interviews or machine learning positions
and the attempt here is to probably
consolidate 30 most commonly asked
questions and to help you in answering
these questions we tried our best to
give you the best possible answers but
of course what is more important here is
rather than the theoretical knowledge
you need to kind of add to the answers
or supplement your answers with your own
experience the responses that we put
here are a bit more generic in nature so
that if there are some Concepts that you
are not clear this video will help you
in kind of getting those Concepts
cleared up as well but what is more
important is that you need to supplement
these responses with your own practical
experience okay so with that let's get
started so one of the first questions
that you may face is what are the
different types of machine learning now
what is the best way to respond to this
there are three types of machine
learning if you read any material you
will always be told there are three
types of machine but what is important
is you would probably be better of
emphasizing that there are actually two
main types of emotional learning which
is supervised and unsupervised and then
there is a third type which is
reinforcement learn so supervised
learning is where you have some
historical data and then you feed that
data to your model to learn now you need
to be aware of a keyword that they will
be looking for which is labeled data
right so if you just say pass data or
historical data the impact may not be so
much you need to emphasize on labeled
data so what is labeled data basically
let's say if you are trying to do train
your model for classification you need
to be aware of for your existing data
which class each of the observations
belong to right so that is what is
labeling so it is nothing but a fancy
name you must be already aware but just
make it a point to throw in that keyword
labeled so that will have that impact
so that is what is supervised learning
when you have existing labeled data
which you then use to train your model
that is known as supervised learning and
unsupervised learning is when you don't
have this label data so you have data it
is not labeled so the system has to
figure out a way to do some analysis on
this okay so that is unsupervised
learning and you can then add a few
things like what are the ways of
performing a supervised learning and
unsupervised learning or what are some
of the techniques so supervised learning
we we perform or we do regression and
classification and unsupervised learning
video clustering and clustering can be
of different types similarly regression
can be a can be of types but you don't
have to probably elaborate so much if
they are asking for just the different
types you can just mention these and
just at a very high level relationship
but if they want you to elaborate give
examples then of course I think there is
a different question that we will see
that
then the third so we have supervised and
we have unsupervised and then
reinforcement you need to provide a
little bit of information around that as
well because it is sometimes a little
difficult to come up with a good
definition for reinforcement so you may
have to little bit elaborate on how
reinforcement learning works works right
so reinforcement learning works in in
such a way that it basically has two
parts to it one is the agent and the
environment and the agent basically is
working inside of this environment and
it is given a Target that it has to
change and every time it is moving in
the direction of the target so the age
it basically has to take has some action
and every time it takes an action which
is moving uh the agent towards the
Target right towards a goal a Target is
nothing but a goal then it is rewarded
and every time it is going in a
direction where it is away from the goal
then it is punished so that is the way
you can little bit explain and this is
used primarily or very very impactful or
teaching the system to learn games and
so on examples of this are basically
used in alphago you can throw that as an
example where alphaco used reinforcement
learning to actually learn to play the
game of Go and finally it defeated the
go world champion all right this much of
information that would be good enough
then there could be a question on
overfitting so the the question could be
what is overfitting and how can you
avoid it so what is overfitting so let's
first try to understand the concept
because sometimes overfitting maybe a
little bit
overfitting is a situation where the
model has kind of memorized the data so
this is an equivalent of memorizing the
data so we can draw an analogy so that
it becomes
we can explain this now let's say you're
teaching a child about recognizing some
fruits or something like that and you're
teaching this child about recognizing
let's say three fruits apples oranges
and pineapples okay so this is a small
child and for the first time you're
teaching the child to recognize fruits
then so what will happen so this is very
much like that is your training data set
so what you will do is you will take a
basket of fruits which consists of
apples oranges and pineapples
and you take this basket to this child
and there may be let's say hundreds of
these fruits so you take this basket to
this child and keep showing each of this
root and then first time obviously the
child will not know what it is so you
show an apple and you say hey this is
Apple then you show maybe an orange and
say this is orange and so on and then
again you keep repeating that right so
till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
and then the process what has happened
the child has pretty much memorized
these so even before you finish that
basket right by the time you are halfway
through the child has learned about
recognizing the Apple orange and
pineapple now what will happen after
halfway through initially you remember
it made mistakes in recognizing but
halfway through now it has learned so
every time you show a fruit it will
exactly 100 accurately it will identify
it will say the child will say this is
an apple this is an orange and if you
show a pineapple it will say this is a
pineapple
that means it has kind of memorized this
data now let's say you bring another
basket of fruits and it will have a mix
of maybe apples which were already there
in the previous set but it will also
have in addition to Apple it will
probably have a banana or maybe another
fruit like a jackfruit right so this is
an equivalent of your test data set
which the child has not seen before some
parts of it it probably has seen like
the apples it has seen but this banana
and Jackfruit it has not seen so then
what will happen in the first round
which is an equivalent of your training
data set towards the end it has 100
percent it was telling you what the
fruits are right Apple was accurately
recognized orange or I was accurately
recognized and pineapples were
accurately recognized right so that is
like a hundred percent accuracy but now
when you get another a fresh set which
we're not a part of the original one
what will happen all the apples maybe it
will be able to recognize correctly but
all the others like the Jackfruit or the
banana will not be recognized by the
child right so this is an analogy this
is an equivalent of overfitting so what
has happened during the training process
it is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low loss right
so that is the technical term so the
loss is pretty much zero and accuracy is
pretty much hundred percent whereas when
you use testing there will be a huge
error which means the loss will be
pretty high and therefore the accuracy
will be also low okay this is known as
overfitting this is basically a process
where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is the extension of
this question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what we call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for avoiding
overfitting and within regularization
there can be a few other subtypes like
drop out in case of neural networks and
a few other examples but I think if you
give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like quick
questions that will be more to stop you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set machine learning model and how
is the split
the question can be
so in machine learning when we are
trying to train the model so we have a
three-step process we train the model
and then we test the model and then once
we are satisfied with the test only then
we deploy the model so what happens in
the train and test is that you remember
the labeled data so let's say you have
1000 records with labeling information
now one way of doing it is you use all
the Thousand records for training and
then maybe right which means that you
have exposed all this thousand records
during the training process and then you
take a small set of the same data and
then you say okay I will test it with
this okay and then you probably what
will happen you may get some good
results all right but there is a flaw
there what is the flaw this is very
similar to human beings it is like you
are showing this model the entire data
as a part of training okay so obviously
it has become familiar with the entire
data so when you're taking a part of
that again and you're saying that I want
to test it obviously you will get good
results so that is not a very accurate
way of testing so that is the reason
what we do is we have the label data of
this thousand records or whatever we set
aside before starting the training
process we set aside a portion of that
data and we call that test set and the
remaining we call as training set and we
use only this for training our model now
the training process remember is not
just about passing one round of this
data set so let's say now your training
set has 800 records it is not just one
time you pass this 800 records what you
normally do is you actually as a part of
the training you may ask this data
through the model multiple times so this
thousand records may go through the
model maybe 10 15 20 times still the
training is perfect till the accuracy is
high till the errors are minimized okay
now so which is fine which means that
your that is what is known as the model
has seen your data and gets familiar
with your data and now when you bring
your test day
what will happen is the is this like
some
samples that is where the real test is
now you have trained the model and now
you are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like a realistic situation
because when the model is deployed that
is what will happen it will receive some
new data not the data that it has
already seen right so this is a
realistic test so you put some new data
so this data which you have set aside is
for the model it is new and if it is
able to accurately predict the values
that means your training has worked okay
the model got trained properly but let's
say while you are testing this with this
test data you are getting lot of errors
that means you need to probably either
change your model or retrain with more
data and things like that now coming
back to the question of how do you split
this what should be the ratio there is
no fixed uh number again this is like
individual preferences some people split
it into 50 50 test and 50 training Some
people prefer to have a larger amount
for training and a smaller amount for
test so they can go by either 60 40 or
70 30 or some people even go with some
odd numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two-thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something
has to be this you can go by your
individual preference all right then you
may have questions around data handling
data manipulation or what you call data
management or Preparation so these are
all some questions around that area
there is again no one answer one single
good answer to this it really varies
from situation to situation
depending on what exactly is the problem
what kind of data it is how critical it
is what kind of data is missing and what
is the type of corruption so there are a
whole lot of things this is a very
generic question and therefore you need
to be little careful about responding to
this as well so probably have to
illustrate this again if you have
experience in doing this kind of work in
handling data you can illustrate with
examples saying that I was on one
project where I received this kind of
data these were the columns where data
was not filled or these were the this
many rows where the data was missing
that would be in fact a perfect way to
respond to this question but if you
don't have that obviously you have to
provide some good answer I think it
really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the missing data or corrupt
data now let's take a few examples now
let's say you have data where some
values in some of the columns are
missing and you have pretty much half of
your data having these missing values in
terms of number of rows okay that could
be one situation another situation could
be that you have records or data missing
but when you do some initial calculation
how many records are corrupt or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like a 10 percent okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so it is not so Mission
critical and it is okay to let's say get
rid of these records so obviously one of
the easiest ways of handling the data
part or missing data is remove those
records or remove those observations
from your analysis so that is the
easiest way to do but then the downside
is as I said in as in the first case if
let's say 50 percent of your data is
like that because some column or the
other is missing so it is not like every
in every place in every Row the same
column is missing but you have in maybe
10 percent of the records column one is
missing and another ten percent column
two is missing another 10 percent column
three is missing and so on and so forth
so it adds up to maybe half of your data
set so you cannot completely remove half
of your data set then the whole purpose
is lost okay so then how do you handle
then you need to come up with ways of
filling up this data with some
meaningful value right that is one way
of handling so when we say meaningful
value what is that meaningful value
let's say for a particular column you
might want to take a mean value for that
column and fill wherever the data is
missing fill up with that mean value so
that when you are doing the calculations
your analysis is not completely way off
so you have values which are not missing
first of all so your system will work
number two these values are not so
completely out of whack that your whole
analysis goes for a task right there may
be situations where if the missing
values instead of putting mean may be a
good idea to fill it up with the minimum
value or with a zero so or with a
maximum value again as I said there are
so many possibilities so there is no
like one correct answer for this you
need to basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as I
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question
okay so then the next question can be
how can you choose a classifier based on
a training set data size so again this
is one of those questions where you
probably do not have like a one size
fits-all answer first of all you may not
let's say decide your classifier based
on the training set size maybe not the
best way to decide the type of the
classified and even if you have to there
are probably some thumb rules which we
can use but then again every time so in
my opinion the best way to respond to
this question is you need to try out few
classifiers irrespective of the size of
the data and you need to then decide on
your particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so you will never be
able to just buy if somebody defines a
problem to you and somebody even if they
show the data to you or tell you what is
the data or even the size of the data I
don't think there is a way to really say
that yes this is the classifier that
will work here no that's not the right
way so you need to still you know test
it out get the data try out a couple of
classifiers and then only you will be in
a position to decide which classifier to
use you try out multiple classifiers see
which one gives the best accuracy and
only then you can decide then you can
have a question around confusion Matrix
so the question can be explained
confusion Matrix right so confusion
Matrix I think the best way to explain
it is by taking an example and drawing
like a small diagram otherwise it can
really become tricky so my suggestion is
to take a piece of pen and paper and
explain it by drawing a small Matrix and
confusion Matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification learning process and when
you get the results when the our model
predicts the results you compare it with
the actual value and try to find out
what is the accuracy okay so in this
case let's say this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and it is a binary
Matrix so you have the actual values
which is the labeled data right and
which is so you have how many yes and
how many know so you have that
information and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many you
know right so the total actual values
the total yes is 12 plus 130 and they
are shown here and the actual value
those are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is
what this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are 1 plus 9 10 nodes okay so this is
the way to look at this confusion Matrix
okay and uh out of this what is the
meaning convey so there are two or three
things that needs to be explained out
right the first thing is for a model to
be accurate the values across the
diagonal should be high like in this
case right that is one number two the
total sum of these values is equal to
sum in this Matrix the numbers is equal
to the size of the test data set and the
diagonal values indicate the accuracy so
by just by looking at it you can
probably have a idea about is this uh an
accurate model is the model being
accurate if they're all spread out
equally in all these four boxes that
means probably the accuracy is not very
good okay now how do you calculate the
accuracy itself right how do you
calculate the accuracy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 plus 12 21 and divide
it by the total so in this case what
will it be let me take a pen so your
your diagonal values is equal if I say t
is equal to 12 plus 9 so that is 21
right and the total data set is equal to
right we just calculated it is 25 so
what is your accuracy it is 21 by your
accuracy is equal to 21 by 25 and this
turns out to be about 85 percent right
so this is 85 percent so that is our
accuracy okay so this is the way you
need to explain draw diagram Give an
example and maybe it may be a good idea
to be paired with an example so that it
becomes easy for you don't have to
calculate those numbers on the fly right
so a couple of hints are that you take
some numbers which are with which add up
to 100 that is always a good idea so you
don't have to really do this complex
calculations so the total value will be
100 and then diagonal values you divide
once you find the diagonal values that
is equal to your percentage okay all
right so the next question can be a
related question about false positive
and false negative so what is false
positive and what is false negative now
once again the best way to explain this
is using a piece of paper and then
otherwise it will be pretty difficult to
so we use the same example of the
confusion Matrix
and we can explain that so A confusion
Matrix looks somewhat like this and when
we just
somewhere like this and we continue with
the previous example where this is the
actual value this is the predicted value
and in the actual value we have 12 plus
1 13 yeses and 3 plus 9 12 nose and the
predicted values there are 12 plus the
15 yeses and 1 plus 9 10 loss okay now
this particular case which is the false
positive what is a false positive first
of all the second word which is positive
okay is referring to the predicted value
so that means the system has predicted
it as a positive but the real value so
this is what the false comes from but
the real value is not positive okay that
is the way you should understand this
term false positive or even false
negative so false positive so positive
is what your system has predicted so
where is that system predicted this is
the one positive is what yes so you
basically consider this row okay now if
you consider this row so this is this is
all positive values this entire row is
positive values okay now the false
positive is the one which where the
value actual value is negative predicted
value is positive but the actual value
is negative so this is a false positive
right and here is a true positive so the
predicted value is positive and the
actual value is also positive okay I
hope this is making sense now let's take
a look at what is false negative false
negative so negative is the second term
that means that is the predicted value
that we need to look for so which are
the predicted negative values this row
corresponds to predicted negative values
all right so this row corresponds to
predicted negative values and what they
are asking for false so this is the row
for predicted negative values and the
actual value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is the way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the a predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right 9 is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the steps
involved in the machine learning process
or what are the three steps in the
process of developing a machine learning
model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model
so first of all you try to understand
the problem and try to figure out
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem based on that
you select a few algorithms and then you
start the process of training these
models
so you can either do that or you can
after due diligence you can probably
decide that there is one particular
algorithm that which is more suitable
usually it happens through trial and
error process but at some point you will
decide that okay this is the model we
are going to use okay so in that case we
have the model algorithm and the model
decided and then you need to do the
process of training the model and
testing the model and this is where if
it is supervised learning you split your
data the label data into training data
set and test data set and you use the
training data set to train your model
and then you use the test data set to
check the accuracy whether it is working
fine or not so you test the model before
you actually put it into production
right so once you test the model you're
satisfied it's working fine then you go
to the next level which is putting it
for production and then in production
obviously new data will come and
inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression
you know so this can be an iterative
process so it is not a straightforward
process where you do the training for
the testing and then you move it to
production now so during the training
and test process there may be a
situation where because of either
overfitting or things like that the test
doesn't go through which means that you
need to put that back into the training
process so that can be a an iterative
process not only that even if the
training and test goes through properly
and you deploy the model in production
there can be a situation that the data
that actually comes the real data that
comes with that this model is failing so
in which case you may have to once again
go back to the drawing more or initially
it will be working fine but over a
period of time maybe due to the change
in the nature of the data once again the
accuracy will later rearrate so that is
again a recursive process so once in a
while you need to keep checking whether
the model is working fine or not and if
required you need to tweak it and modify
it and so on and so net net this is a
continuous process of tweaking the model
and testing it and making sure it is up
to date then you might have question
around deep learning so because deep
learning is now associated with AI
artificial intelligence and so on so it
can be as simple as what is deep
learning so I think the best way to
respond to this could be deep learning
is a part of machine learning and then
obviously the question would be then
what is the difference right so deep
learning you need to mention there are
two key parts that interviewer will be
looking for when you are defining deep
learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say scope and deep learning is one
one part of it so then what exactly is
the difference deep learning is
primarily when we are implementing these
our algorithms or when we are using
neural networks for doing our training
and classification and regression and
all that right so when we use neural
network then it is considered as deep
learning and the term deep comes from
the fact that you can have several
layers of neural networks and these are
called Deep neural networks and
therefore the term deep you know deep
learning the other difference between
machine learning and deep learning which
the interviewer may be wanting to hear
is that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and this data has several let's say if
it is a regular table it has several
columns now each of these columns
actually has information about a feature
right so if we are trying to predict the
height weight and so on and so forth so
these are all features of human beings
let's say we have census data and we
have all this so those are the features
now there may be probably 50 or 100 in
some cases there may be 100 such
features now all of them do not
contribute to our model right so we as a
data scientist we have to decide whether
we should take all of them all the
features or we should throw away some of
them because again if we take all of
them number one of course your accuracy
will probably get affected but also
there is a computational part so if you
have so many teachers and then you have
so much data it becomes very tricky so
in case of machine learning we manually
take care of identifying the features
that do not contribute to the learning
process and thereby we eliminate those
features and so on right so this is
known as feature engineering and in
machine learning we do that manual
whereas in deep learning where we use
neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably will add value to your response
all right so the next question is what
is the difference between or what are
the differences between machine learning
and deep learning so here this is a
quick comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
missions to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and it needs only a small amount of data
for training and then works well on low
end system so you don't need a large
Mission and most features need to be
identified in advance and manually coded
so basically the feature engineering
part is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then come so that is
about the machine learning part in deep
learning deep learning basically enables
machines to take decisions with the help
of artificial neural networks so here in
deep learning we use neural line so that
is the key differentiator between
machine learning and deep learning and
usually heat learning involves a large
amount of data and therefore the
training also requires usually the
training process requires high-end
machines
needs a lot of computing power and the
Machine learning features are the or the
feature engineering is done
automatically so the neural networks
takes care of doing the feature
engineering as well and in case of deep
learning therefore it is said that the
problem is handled end to end so this is
a quick comparison between machine
learning and deep learning in case you
have that kind of then you might get a
question around the uses of machine
learning or some real life applications
of machine learning in modern business
the question may be worded in different
ways but the meaning is how exactly is
machine learning used or actually
supervised machine learning it could be
a very specific question around
supervised decision learning so this is
like give examples of supervised machine
learning use of supervised machine
learning in modern business so that
could be the next so there are quite a
few examples or quite a few use cases if
you will for supervised definition
learning the very common one is email
spam detection so you want to train your
application or your system to detect
between spam and non-spam so this is a
very common business application of a
supervised machine learning so how does
this work the way it works is that you
obviously have historical data above of
your emails and they are categorized as
spam and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is Spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have labeled data you already have
emails which are tagged as spam or not
and then you use that to train your
model right so this is one example now
there are a few industry specific
applications for supervised machine
learning one of the very common ones is
in healthcare Diagnostics in healthcare
Diagnostics you have these images and
you want to train models to detect
whether from a particular image whether
it can find out if the person is sick or
not whether a person has cancer or not
right so this is a very good example of
supervised machine learning here the way
it works is that existing images it
could be x-ray images it will be MRI or
any of these images are available and
they are saying that okay this x-ray
image is deflective of the person has an
illness or it could be cancer whichever
illness right so it is stacked as
defective or clear or good image and
effectively something like that so we
come up with a binary or it could be
multi-class as well saying that this is
defective to 10 percent this is 25 and
so on but let's keep it simple you can
give an example of just a binary
classification that would be good enough
so you can say that in healthcare
Diagnostics using which we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when New
Image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer
right so I think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
unsupervised and so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
art of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
Industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of diagnostic images
just let's say take X-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
their images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good and
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so I know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no quick and easy
the definition for semi-supervised
machine learning this is the only way
probably to explain this concept
we may have another question as what are
unsupervised machine learning techniques
or what are some of the techniques used
for performing unsupervised machine
learning so it can be worded in
different ways so how do we answer this
question so unsupervised learning you
can say that there are two types
clustering and Association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together
then Association you can I think the
best way to explain Association is with
an example in case of Association you
try to find out how the items are linked
linked for example if somebody bought
maybe a laptop or the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying and laptops are also
buying a mouse so that means there is an
association between laptops and
people who are buying bread are also
buying butter so that is the association
that can be created so this is
unsupervised learning one of the
techniques links okay all right then we
have very fundamental question what is
the difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so machine
learning these are the two main types of
machine learning supervised and
unservised and in case of supervised and
again here probably the key word that
the person may be wanting to hear is
labeled data now very often people say
we have historical data and if we run it
it is supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot
so it is it's very key to understand
that we put in that keyword label okay
so when we have labeled data for
training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have labeled data then we use
unsupervised learning and there are
different algorithms available to
perform both of these
so there can be another question a
little bit more theoretical and
conceptual in nature this is about
inductive machine learning and
active machine learning so the question
can be what is the difference between
inductive machine learning and deductive
machine learning or somewhat in that
manner so that the exact phrase or exact
question
three they can ask for examples and
things like that but that could be the
question so let's first understand what
is inductive and deductive Trading
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with a small example I think that always
helps so whenever you're doing some
explanation try as much as possible as I
said to give examples from your work
experience or give some analogies and
that will also help a lot in explaining
as well and for the interviewer also to
understand so here we'll take an example
or rather we will use an analogy so
inductive training is when we induce
some knowledge or the learning process
into a person without the person
actually experiencing it what can be an
example so we can probably tell the
person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage right so this is
inductive learning compared to that what
is deductive learning so here you draw
conclusion or the person draws
conclusion out of experience so we will
stick to the analogy so compared to the
showing a video Let's assume a person is
allowed to play with fire right and then
he figures out that if he puts his
finger it's burning or you throw
something into the fire it burns so he
is learning through experience so this
is known as deductive learning okay so
you can have applications or models that
can be trained using inductive learning
or deductive learning all right I think
probably that explanation will be
sufficient the next question is are knnn
and K means clustering similar to one
another or are they same right because
the letter K is kind of common between
them okay so let us take a little while
to understand what these two are one is
KNN another is K means a k n stands for
K nearest neighbors and K means of
course is the clustering mechanism now
these two are completely different
except for the letter K being common
between them KN is completely different
K means clustering is
KNN is a classification process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k-means clustering is
actually a unsupervised okay when you
have K and N when you want to implement
k n n which is basically K nearest
neighbors the value of K is a number so
you can say k is equal to 3 you want to
implement k n n with K is equal to 3 so
which means that it performs the
classification in such a way that how
does it perform the classification so it
will take three nearest objects and
that's why it's called nearest neighbor
so basically uh based on the distance it
will try to find out its nearest objects
that are let's say three of the nearest
objects and then it will check whether
the class they belong to which class
right so if all three belong to one
particular class obviously this new
object is also classified as that
particular
but it is possible that they may be from
two or three different classes okay so
let's say they are from two classes and
then they are from two classes now
usually you take a odd number you assign
odd number two so if there are three of
them and two of them belong to one class
and then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of K is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven it can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking K as3 the object is
probably in one particular class but if
you take K is equal to 5 maybe the
object will belong to a different class
because when you're taking three of them
probably two of them belong to a class
one and one belong to class two whereas
when you take five of them it is
possible that only two of them belong to
class one and the three of them belong
class two so which means that this
object will belong to class 2 right so
you see that so it is the class
allocation can vary depending on the
value of K now K means on the other hand
is a clustering process and it is
unsupervised where what it does is the
system will basically identify how the
objects are how close the objects are
with respect to some of their features
okay and but the similarity of course is
the the letter K and in case of K means
also we specify its value and it could
be three or five or seven there is no
technical limit as such but it can be
any number of clusters that you can
create okay so based on the value that
you provide the system will create that
many clusters of similar objects there
is a similarity to that extent that K is
a number in both the cases but actually
these two are completely different
processes
we have what is known as naive based
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive base is the name of
the person who found this classifier or
who developed this classifier which is
not 100 True base is the name of the
person bais is the name of the person
but naive is not the name of the person
right so naive is basically an English
word and that has been added here
because of the nature of his particular
classifier noise classifier is a
probability based classifier and it
makes some assumptions that presence of
one feature of a class is not related to
the presence of any other feature of
maybe other classes right so which is
not a very strong or not a very what do
you say accurate assumption because
these features can be related and so on
but even if we go with this assumption
this whole algorithm works very well
even with this assumption and that is
the good side of it but the term comes
from there so that is the explanation
that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement or
it can be any game so the best way to
explain this is again to talk a little
bit about what reinforcement learning is
about and then elaborate on that to
explain the process so first of all
reinforcement learning as an environment
and an agent and the agent is basically
performing some actions in order to
achieve a certain goal and this goals
can be anything either it is related to
game then the goal could be that you
have to score very high score value High
number or it could be that your number
of lives should be as high as possible
don't lose life so this could be some of
them a more advanced examples could be
for driving the automotive industry
self-driving cars they actually also
make use of reinforcement learning to
teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize
it is rewarded and every time it takes a
step which goes against that core and
contrary or in the reverse Direction it
is penalized okay so it is like a
keratin as
how do you use this to create a game of
chess so to create a system to play a
game of chess now the way this works is
and this could probably go back to this
alphago example where alphaco defeated a
human Champion so the way it works is in
reinforcement learning the system is
allowed for example in this case we're
talking about Chess so we allow the
system to first of all watch playing a
game of chess could be with a human
being or it or it be the system itself
there are computer games of Chess right
so either this new learning system has
to watch that game or watch a human
being play the game because this is
reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent it works on
that so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's at right at the beginning the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it it just starts by
observing how you are playing so it will
make some random moves and keep losing
badly but then what happens is over a
period of time so you need to now allow
the system or you need to play with the
system not just one two three four or
five times but hundreds of times
thousands of times maybe even hundreds
of thousands of times and that's exactly
how alphago has done it played millions
of games between itself and the system
right so for the game of chess also you
need to do something like that you need
to allow the system to play chess and
then learn on its own over a period of
habitation so I think you can probably
explain it to this much to this extent
and I should
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem I would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm I am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have SPM you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is how
okay so we have to try out a bunch of
algorithms see which one gives us the
best performance best accuracy accuracy
and then decide to go with that
particular algorithm so in machine
learning a lot of it happens through
trial and error there is no real
possibility that anybody can just by
looking at the problem or understanding
the problem tell you that okay in this
particular situation this is exactly the
algorithm that you should use then the
questions may be around application of
machine learning and this question is
specifically around how Amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does a recommendation engine
work this is basically the question is
all about so the recommendation engine
again Works based on various inputs that
are provided obviously something like uh
you know Amazon a website or e-commerce
site like Amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer Behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they're also
buying something else so this kind of
Association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and Link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build association
between items saying that somebody
buying this is also buying this that is
one part of it then they also profile
the users right based on their age their
gender their geographic location they
will do some profiling and then when
somebody is logging in and when somebody
is shopping kind of the mapping of these
two things are done they try to identify
obviously if you have logged in then
they know who you are and your
information is available like for
example your age maybe your gender and
where you're located what you purchased
earlier right so all this is taken and
the recommendation engine basically uses
all this information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user so
that is how the recommendation engine
work all right then the question can be
something very basic like when will you
go for classification versus regression
right when do you do classification
instead of regression or when we do use
classification instead of regression now
yes so so this is basically going back
to the understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values another is the
continuous value so for regression if we
are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
tiger something like that so that is a
classification problem or it can be that
is a multi-class classification problem
it could be binary classification
problem like for example whether a
customer will buy or he will not buy
that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not it's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continue so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your Concepts and
so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
Developers
so I think the main thing here is he is
looking at probably understanding your
Concepts in terms of uh what is the
algorithm you will use or what is your
understanding about difference between
classification and regression
and things like that right and the
process of course the methodology and
the process so the best way to go about
responding to this is we say that okay
this is a classification problem problem
because we want to find out whether an
email is a spam or not spam so that we
can apply the filter accordingly so
first thing is to identify what type of
a problem it is so we have identified
that it is a classification then the
second step may be to find out what kind
of algorithm to use now since this is a
binary classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as I said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support Vector machines for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want to we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually so and you actually
will have three models let's say you are
trying to test out three algorithms so
you will obviously have three models so
you need to try all three models and
test them out as well see which one
gives the best accuracy and then you
decide that you will go with that model
okay so training and test will be done
and then you zero in on one particular
model and then you say okay this is the
model will you use we will use and then
go ahead and Implement that or put that
in production so that is the way you
design a specific the next question is
about random Forest what is random form
so this is a very straightforward
question however the response you need
to be again a little careful while we
all know what is random Forest
explaining this can sometimes be tricky
so one thing is random Forest is kind of
in one way it is an extension of
decision trees because it is basically
nothing but you have multiple decision
trees and trees will basically we will
use for doing if it is classification
mostly it is classification you will use
the the trees for classification and
then you use voting for finding that the
final class so that is the underlying
but how will you explain this how will
you respond to this so first thing
obviously we will say that random Forest
is one of the algorithms and the more
important thing that you need to
probably the interviewer is is waiting
to here is Ensemble learner right so
this is one type of Ensemble learner
what is Ensemble learner Ensemble
learner is like a combination of
algorithms so it is a learner which
consists of more than one algorithm or
more than one or maybe models okay so in
case of random Forest the algorithm is
the same but instead of using one
instance of it we use multiple instances
of it and we use so in a way that is a
random Forest is an ensemble there are
other types of Ensemble Learners where
we have like reuse different algorithms
itself so you have one maybe logistic
regression and a decision tree combined
together and so on and so forth or there
are other ways like for example
splitting the data in a certain way and
so on so that's all about Ensemble we
will not go into that but random Forest
itself I think the interviewer will be
happy to hear this word Ensemble
Learners and so then you go and explain
how the random Forest works so if the
random Forest is used for classification
then we use what is known as a voting
mechanism so basically how does it work
let's say your random Forest consists of
100 trees okay and each observation you
pass through this forest and each
observation let's say it is a
classification problem binary
classification zero or one and you have
100 trees now if 90 trees say that it is
a zero and ten of the trees say it is a
one you take the majority you may take a
vote and since 90 of them are saying
zero you classify this as zero then you
take the next observation and so on so
that is the way random Forest works for
classification if it is a regression
problem it's somewhat similar but the
only thing is instead of what what we
will do is sorry in regression remember
what happens you actually calculate a
value right so for example you're using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
hundred trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
Forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this Forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the hundred trees right
so this is also a way of reducing the
error so maybe if you have only one tree
and that one tree makes a error it is
basically hundred percent wrong or 100
right right but if you have on the other
hand if you have a bunch of trees you
are basically indicating that reducing
that
so that is the way random Forest works
so the next question is considering the
long list of machine learning algorithms
how will you decide on which one to OLS
so once again here there is no way to
outright say that this is the algorithm
that we will use for a given data set
this is a very good question but then
the response has to be like again there
will not be a one-size-fits all so we
need to first of all you can probably
shorten the list in terms of by saying
okay whether it is a classification
problem or it is a regression problem to
that extent you can probably shorten the
list because you don't have to use all
of them if it is a classification
problem you only can pick from the
classification algorithms right so for
example if it's a classification you
cannot use linear regression algorithm
or if it is a regression problem you
cannot use svm or maybe now you can use
svm but maybe a logistic regression
right so to that extent you can probably
shorten the list but still you will not
be able to 100 decide on saying that
this is the exact algorithm that I am
going to use so the way to go about is
you choose a few algorithms based on
what the problem is you try out your
data you train some models of these
algorithms check which one gives you the
lowest error or the highest accuracy and
based on that you choose that particular
algorithm okay all right then there can
be questions around bias and variance so
the question can be what is bias and
variance in machine learning uh so you
just need to give out a definition for
each of these for example a bias in
machine learning it occurs when the
predicted values are far away from the
actual value so that is the bias okay
and whereas they are all all the values
are probably they are far off but they
are very near to each other though the
predicted values are close to each other
right while they are far off from the
actual value but they are close to each
other you see the difference so that is
and then the other part is your variance
now variance is when the predicted
values are all over the place right so
the variance is high that means it may
be close to the Target but it is kind of
very scattered so the points the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of bias the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the Target but
here they may be close to the Target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
trade-off between bias and variance yes
I think this is a interesting question
because these two are heading in
different directions so for example if
you try to minimize the bias variance
will keep going high and if you try to
minimize the variance bias will keep
going high and there is no way you can
minimize both of them so you need to
have a trade-off saying that okay this
is the level at which I I will have my
bias and this is the level at which I
will have variance so the trade-off is
that pretty much uh attack you you
decide what is the level you will
tolerate for your bias and what is the
level you will tolerate for variance and
a combination of these two in such a way
that your final results are not way off
and having a trade-off will ensure that
the results are consistent right so that
is basically the output is consistent
and which means that they are close to
each other and they are also accurate
right that means they are as close to
the Target as possible right so if
either of these is high then one of them
will go off the track define precision
and Recall now again here I think it
would be best to draw a diagram and take
up in the confusion Matrix and it is
very simple the definition is like a
formula your Precision is true positive
by true positive plus false positive and
your recall is true positive by true
positive plus false negative okay so
that's you can just show it in a
mathematical way that's pretty much you
know
easiest way to define so the next
question can be about decision tree what
is decision tree pruning and why is it
so basically decision trees are really
simple to implement and understand but
one of the drawbacks of decision trees
is that it can become highly complicated
as it grows right and the rules and
conditions can become very created and
this can also lead to overfitting which
is basically that during training you
will get 100 accuracy but when you're
doing testing you'll get a lot of Errors
so that is the reason pruning needs to
be done so the purpose or the reason for
doing this tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on
overfitting and what is decision trip
rolling it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then there are several internal
nodes and then you have the leaf nodes
now if there are too many of these
internal nodes that is when you face the
problem of overfitting and pruning is
the process of reducing those internal
nodes all right so the next question can
be what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is one of
the techniques used for performing
classification especially binary
classification now there is something
special about logistic regression and
there are a couple of things you need to
be careful about first of all the name
is a little confusing it is called
logistic regression but it is used for
classification so the scan be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really enough
required and they can also ask this like
a request
request so that is one second thing is
the term logistic has nothing to do with
the usual Logistics that we talk about
but it is derived from the log so that
the mathematical derivation was log and
therefore the name
so what is logistic regression and how
is it used so logistic regression is
used for binary classification and the
output of a logistic regression is
either a zero or a one and it varies so
it's basically it calculates a
probability between 0 and 1 and we can
set a threshold that can vary typically
it is 0.5 so any value above 0.5 is
considered as 1 and if the probability
is below 0.5 it is considered as 0. so
that is the way we calculate the
probability of the system calculates the
probability and based on the threshold
it sets a value of 0 or 1 which is like
a binary classification zero or one okay
then we have a question around K nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain K nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is the K nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the K is a
number it is a an integer and this is
variable and we can Define what the
value of K should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
I think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs right so you go about as the
name suggests if you go about finding
the nearest neighbors right the points
which are closest to this and how many
of them you will find that is what is
defined by K now let's say our initial
value of K was 5 okay so you will find
find the K the five nearest data points
so in this case as it is Illustrated
these are the five nearest data points
but then all five do not belong to the
same class or cluster so there are one
belonging to this cluster one the second
one belonging to this cluster two three
of them belonging to this third cluster
okay so how do you decide that's exactly
the reason we should as much as possible
try to assign an odd number so that it
becomes easier to assign this so in this
case you see that the majority actually
if there are multiple classes then you
go with the majority so since three of
these items belong to this class we
assign which is basically the in in this
case the green or the tennis or the
third cluster as I was talking
right so we assign it to this third
class so in this case it is uh that's
how it is decided okay so K nearest
neighbors the first thing is to identify
the number of neighbors that are
mentioned as K so in this case it is K
is equal to 5 so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the new data
point is assigned to that class okay so
that's pretty much how K nearest
neighbors work today we are going to
talk about some of the essential
programming interview questions for a
data scientist role now since python is
widely used programming language for
data science machine learning and deep
learning we will be solving our problems
in the Python programming language using
jupyter notebook so let's begin with our
first question our first question is
how do you get a list of all the keys in
a dictionary
now in Python for data science data
structures play an important role to
store and manipulate data dictionary is
one such data structure that is declared
using curly braces and they are written
as key value pairs
you can see on the screen I have my
dictionary called D and it is assigned
using curly braces
now to get a list of all the keys in a
dictionary we use the dot Keys function
now let me take you to my jupyter
notebook so here is my jupyter notebook
and you can see my first cell I have my
dictionary defined
so the name of the dictionary is D and
it has the key values the keys are the
country names and the values are the
capitals of each country so I have India
and the capital is New Delhi then I have
USA the capital is Washington similarly
I have Spain Madrid and we have Germany
and Berlin
now India USA France Spain all these are
my keys so to get the keys I'll use the
dot Keys function so I'll write my
dictionary name that is d dot
I'll give keys
close the brackets and hit shift enter
you can see these are the list of my
keys in the dictionary d
all right
okay
now let's move to our next question
so our next question is what do you mean
by list comprehension in Python
so list comprehensions are a sort and
easy way to define and create new lists
based on existing lists
so suppose you want to iterate through a
list and find all the even numbers in
the list you can either use a for Loop
and an if condition as shown here or you
can write a list comprehension to do it
in one line of code you can see this is
my list comprehension
so let me show you both the ways
all right so here on my jupyter notebook
let me declare my list as L equal to
I'll pass in a few numbers let's say 5
comma 12
10 we have 14
9 and let's say the last element in the
list is 6.
all right let me run this list
okay now
let me create an empty list let's say
list one and let this be an empty list
with square brackets
then
I'll use the looping construct to find
the even elements in the list so I'll
write a for Loop called
for item in
my list l
I'll give colon
then I'll give my condition if
item
percentage 2 is equal to equal to 0
which means if the remainder is 0
then
I'll
append the items
to my empty list which is list one so
I'll write list one dot append
and I'll pass in the argument by item
now
let me go ahead and
print my list
I'll write print
the
final list
using a for Loop
I'll give colon give a comma
and pass in my new list name which is
list one
now let's run this you can see
using this for Loop and the if condition
I have got all the even elements in my
list which was L you can see my original
list and 12 10 14 and 6 where all the
even numbers present in my list now this
task you can do it using list
comprehensions as well
so let me show you how to do that
so I have my list
defined let me just copy this here I'll
paste it
and now
I'll create another variable which is
list one
I'll write equal to
now here
using square brackets I'll write item
for
item in
l
and I'll give my if condition as if
item
percentage to
is equal to equal to 0
then
I'll print my resultant list so I'll
write print
let's say
resultant
list using
list comprehension
okay
I'll give a colon then a comma and I'll
pass in my new list which is list one
so here
whatever is there
in my square brackets
is called the list comprehension
technique
let me just print this and I'll get the
same result so these are my even numbers
all right
so let's move to the third question so
our third question is
given a list of numbers find the squares
of the numbers using the map function in
Python
now the map function calls the specified
function for each element of an iterable
and returns a result
so let me show you an example to find
out squares of a list of numbers using
the map function
okay
so let's first Define a function called
Square so I'm using my def keyword and
I'll pass in my user defined function
name as square and I'll give my
parameter as X
and
I want to return
the square of X which is X
star X
all right and then let me Define my
list of numbers so I'll
pass in a variable called num and let's
say I want to find the squares of five
numbers one two three comma four comma
five
here
I'll pass in another variable which will
store the resultant list
so I'll write num underscore
squared
equal to here I'll use my map function
so map function takes in two parameters
first it will take in
the user defined function name which is
square here and the list of numbers
which is num
I'll run a for Loop I'll write 4 let me
just scroll down
I'll write for
num in
num underscore squared
print
num
so this is my map function
so
it will map all the elements in the list
to this function which is square
I'll just print it you can see
we have the list of squares from the num
list which has
the elements one two three four and five
now moving ahead
coming to our fourth question
the fourth question is on to write a
program that will filter out the numbers
divisible by 3 from a tuple using the
Lambda functions
so Lambda functions are Anonymous
functions that are not defined by the
def keyword in Python
so here you can see I have the example
so this is a tuple I have defined and
using filter along with the Lambda
function I am trying to find out the
numbers that are divisible by 3 and
finally I am printing those numbers so
let's do it on our jupyter notebook
all right so we are on the jupyter
notebook so first I'll Define a tuple
let's say
the variable name is my underscore dup
which stands for my Tuple and
using brackets I'll pass in my Tuple
values let's say 5 12 10 18
we have 43 9 7
11 and let's say six
so you can see these are the numbers
present in my Tuple
now
I'll create
another variable called new Tuple
and I'll use my Tuple function
and inside the Tuple function I'll use
the filter function that will filter out
only the values
that are divisible by 3
and now I'll write my Lambda function so
notice this clearly
how to use a Lambda function I'll use
the keyword Lambda
and then
I'll pass in a variable X
now this
should consider only those values
that are divisible by 3 so I'll write X
percentage 3 should be equal to equal to
0.
and
I'll give
my Tuple
as the variable here
all right
now we have declared our Lambda function
let's just go ahead and print my new
Tuple which is new underscore tup
so here you can see I have my Tuple
function
inside the Tuple function I'll use my
filter function that will filter only
those values divisible by 3 and to
filter those values I have used my
Lambda function here and passed in my
original Tuple which is my Tuple
it's actually my top so let's delete the
last two letters
let's just go ahead and print this there
you go you can see we have 12 18 9 and 6
are the only numbers that are divisible
by 3 from this Tuple moving to the next
question
so our next question is how to create a
data frame from a dictionary
Now to create a data frame from a
dictionary you can use the pandas
library and the dot data frame function
now pandas is a popular library in
Python that is used for data
manipulation
so let me show you how you can create an
employee dictionary and then convert
that into a data frame
okay
so here on my Jupiter notebook let me go
ahead and import my pandas Library so
I'll write import
pandas as
PD
and
next let's create my employee dictionary
so I'll write EMP which stands for
employee and and within curly braces
I'll give my key value pairs so my first
column would be the name of the employee
and
let's pass in a list of employee names
I'll write Emmy
let's say we have
Angela
the third employee's name let's say we
have
Samuel
and
let Dany BR fourth employee
I'll give a comma
now the second attribute in our
dictionary will be the age of the
employee
so my key would be age and
let's create a list of age values
I'm assigning random values to those
employee
each
30 and let's say 32
and let's create another
variable called City
here variable refers to the column name
of the data frame
let's say Amy is from New York
then we have
Angela from Chicago
let's say Samuel is from Boston
and we have
Danny from let's say Seattle
okay
so if I run this I have my employee
dictionary created
so if you want to see the dictionary you
can write print and pass
the variable name which is EMP here
so this is my dictionary
now to convert this dictionary into a
data frame you can simply write DF
and
you can give the pandas Library
SPD and use the data frame function
so I'll write data frame
and
I'll pass in my dictionary name which is
EMP here
let's run it
okay so we have successfully created our
data frame now let me just print the
data frame I'll write DF
there you go you can see I have a nice
table here which is actually a data
frame here you can see the indices and
you can see our column names as name
each and City and these are the values
or the rows
all right
now let's see the sixth question we have
so the question is
what is the difference between loc and
iloc in Python
now as data scientists you would often
want to analyze a chunk of data and not
all the rows in it
so loc and iloc functions can help you
fetch specific rows and columns from
your data frame
loc function uses row or column labels
to select and slice data from a data
frame while iloc uses integer index to
select specific rows and columns
remember iloc stands for index location
I'll use a card data frame to show how
loc and iloc works now on your screens
you can see the data frame so it has a
column called brand which has different
brand names such as Ford this Hyundai
Tata Mahindra this maruti the skia
motors
then we have the year in which the car
was manufactured
we have the number of kilometers the car
has run we have the city and the mileage
of the car cubes
so let me first create this data frame
on my jupyter notebook
okay so here on my notepad I have my
code written to create the data frame
that is car I'll just copy this code and
I'll paste it
to this cell
okay let me just run it
so I go on top you can see we have
successfully created our car data frame
now let me go ahead and print this data
frame so I'll write print
in Brackets I'll give my data frame
escar
let me run it all right so here is my
data frame
now suppose you want to see the data
from second row till the fifth row for
brand and City columns so you can use
the loc function so I want my data from
the second row till the fifth row for
brand and City columns so let me show
you how to do that so first I'll write
my data frame name that is car and then
I'll give my function as Loc
and
within brackets I'll give my
row index values so I'll give from 2 to
5 which is second root fifth row and
I'll give my column names as brand
you give a comma and my second column
which I want is City
so here I am using the labeled based
indexing let me just run it there you go
you can see we have the information
available for
the second row third row fourth row and
the fifth row
all right
similarly let's see one more example for
index location based slicing
so suppose you want to see the data from
second third and fourth row for year
kilometers and City columns so for that
you can use the iloc function so I want
the value for
second third and fourth row and the
columns that I want are years kilometers
and the city column
so for that
I'll give my data frame name as car dot
this time I'll use iloc
and within
square brackets I'll give my
row values and the column values
now one thing you should notice here is
if you use iloc Python will exclude the
last index which is the fifth row and
similarly here it will exclude the last
index from the column which is the
fourth column
if I run this
you get the desired result
now
let's see another example let's say this
time I want to print the rows that have
mileage less than 25 for brand and City
columns so you can use a print function
and I'll pass in my data frame as car
and use
Luc here
I'll give my condition as
car
and I want my condition that is mileage
should be
less than 25
and
I want
the brand name
so I'll use a square bracket and give my
brand column
and I also want the city column
okay
let me
close it
if you run this
now these are the brand names Renault
Tata and Kia which have mileage less
than 25 let me just verify this
you can see all these values are less
than 25
similarly you can use the
iloc function as well
I can write print
we'll give car dot iloc
within square brackets I'll give car
and my condition column is mileage
now this should be less than 25
I'll use dot values
and
then I'll give my
column numbers as 0 comma 2.
let me run it
there you go
the same result we have got it using
iloc function this time
and you can see the columns were 0 comma
2 which means we wanted the
First Column which is brand
and the second column which was
kilometers
all right
now moving to our seventh question in
the list of questions that we have
the question is how is list dot append
different from list dot extend
Now list dot append adds its arguments
as a single element to the end of the
list the length of the list increases by
1 here
and list dot extend iterates over its
arguments and adds each element to the
list the length of the list increases by
the number of elements in its arguments
so let me show you
the difference on my jupyter notebook
okay
so let's create a list called list one
equal to
I'll create a list let's say it has some
country names like India
then we have
USA
and I'll consider one more country let's
say
Canada
okay
now let me print the length of this list
also
I'll use the length function for that
all right now
let me append one more list so I'll use
the append function I'll write list one
dot append
and
Within
brackets I'll give my new list which has
two more country names let's say
France and
Spain
okay
and here let me print
list one and let's also print the length
of the list again
I'll use the length function
and my list name which is list one
so just Mark we are using append here
let me run this
there you go
so here you can see
my original list had three elements
since the length is three now when I
appended this new list which had two
elements France and Spain
our size increased by 1 and the length
of the new list is 4.
now
let me just copy this code
and
instead of append let me write extend
so that we can see the difference
between append and extend
so scroll down
run it here you can see
our original list had three elements
but after we extended our
list with two more elements
the length of the new list became five
so these are the
five elements in the list
and here you can see
there were total four elements in the
list
when we appended the new list
okay now moving to our eighth question
suppose you have a car data set which
has a mileage column
you need to create a new field called
MLG that will accept two values
if mileage is less than 25 25 then the
mileage should be high MLG or the value
should be high MLG
now while analyzing data data scientists
often need to create extra columns in
the data frame to add more values that
will help you make your data analysis
more efficient
so here you can see
my data set
it has the brand name year kilometers
City and the mileage column
now if mileage is less than 25 I'll add
the value low MLG to my new column else
if mileage is greater than or equal to
25 I'll add High MLG to my new column
so here you can see my final output
wherever the mileage is less than 25 it
should print low MLG else it should
print high MLG now let's do this on my
jupyter notebook
so we'll use Lambda functions that we
learned earlier to perform this task
I'll write a function let's say f is
equal to
you can call this as a function or a
variable
I'll
give the keyword Lambda and use x as my
parameter
now X should be
low MLG
if
X is less than 25 which is mileage here
else
if it's not less than 25 it should
return High MLG
now
what I'll do is
I'll give my
data frame escar and I'll create my new
column that is MLG
then I'll write
equal to car dot
I'll give my
column name from the original data frame
which is mileage
and I use my apply function
and pass in the variable f
now let's just print this data frame
if I run it
you can see the output here we have
created a new column which is MLG you
can see our new column name was MLG and
these are the results so for Renault
Tata and Kia for the last three rows
since the mileage is less than 25 it
returned low MLG for the remaining it
gave us High MLG
now moving to the ninth question
so this is our next question we want to
create a four Cross Four Matrix and find
the sum of all the diagonal elements in
The Matrix
data scientists often work with multiple
dimensional arrays or multi-dimensional
arrays n matrices to build models this
question is related to an operation on a
four Cross Four Matrix so first we need
to create an array which will be a numpy
array of four Cross Four
shape and then we'll see how to
calculate the diagonal elements or the
sum of the diagonal elements
so I am on my Jupiter notebook first
let's import the numpy library so I'll
write import numpy or numpy as NP
let me run it
okay now
I'll create my four Cross Four trick so
I'll write
m is equal to
NP dot array
and I'll create my
4 cross 4 Matrix
let's say the values are one two three
four in the first row
and in the second row I'll pass 5 comma
6 comma 7 comma 8.
in the third row we'll have 9 10 and 11.
also 12.
and finally we'll have 13
14 15 and 16.
in the fourth row
I'll just run it
now if I print m
you can see this is a 4 cross 4 Matrix
so this is one way of creating a four
Cross Four Matrix which is a bit tedious
and lengthy instead of that you can also
use a range function
so if I write m is equal to
NP Dot
a range function
and here I'll give my values starting
from 1 till
17 so this will actually exclude 17 and
take from 1 to 16.
and I'll give my shape
as 4 comma 4.
let me print it
there you go it has printed the exact
same Matrix that we saw above
all right now to print the diagonal
elements we'll use the diagonal function
so I'll write print
m dot
diagonal
let me just run it
so 1 6 11 and 16 are my diagonal
elements you can see this Matrix 1 6 11
and 16 are my diagonal elements
now to print the sum of all the diagonal
elements I'll use the sum function
so I'll write m dot
diagonal
along with that I'll pass my sum
function
if I run it
so the sum of 1 6 11 and 16 is 34.
okay
so coming to the last question on this
interesting session on programming
interview questions for data scientists
our question is given a vehicle data
frame find the average and maximum
mileage of the vehicles using pandas
so here data scientists use statistical
measures to analyze their data so it is
important to have knowledge of the
statistical functions in Python here is
my vehicle data set and for each brand
of vehicle we want to find the average
and the maximum mileage so let me show
you how to do it
okay so here on the notepad I have my
code written to create the vehicle data
frame I'll just copy it
and paste it on this cell
you can see
we have the brand column the year column
kilometers City mileage here you can see
the different
brand of vehicles let me just create
this data frame first
and let me go ahead and print the
vehicle data frame so I'll write vehicle
and run it
so here is the data frame
now
I want to find the average and maximum
mileage for
each of the brand and then I'll use my
data frame name as vehicle
followed by the group by function
I'll write Group by
and since I want to check for all the
brands so I'll group all the brand of
vehicles
then I'll use an aggregate function
which is egg
and
within curly braces I'll give my column
as mileage
I'll give a colon
and pass in mean which is for average
and I'll use max to find the maximum
mileage
now let's
print it I'll write print
I'll give
a message as the
average and
maximum
mileage
of
vehicles
let me just print the result
I'll run it
you can see it has resulted in an error
the reason is
in vehicle the V is capital
if I run it there you go here you can
see on the left we have the brand names
we have Hyundai this maruti and Tata
because those were the only three brand
of vehicles we had and for each brand
you can see the mean mileage and the
maximum mileage
for maruti it was
26.33 and the maximum mileage is 28
similarly you can see for
data vehicle as well SQL is a widely
used language for querying data from
databases it allows you to store
retrieve manipulate and update data
present in the form of rows and columns
data scientists often work with
structured data that is stored in MySQL
databases Microsoft SQL servers Oracle
databases or even nosql databases such
as mongodb today we will look at a
variety of SQL questions
we'll be using the mySQL database for
our demo throughout the video we'll be
using MySQL workbench and the MySQL
command line to solve the SQL queries
let me show you the database that we
will be using for this demo and the
tables we are going to use
okay so here I am on my SQL workbench
and Below you can see I have a local
instance created I'll just click on it
now it's asking me to enter the password
I'll give my password
and hit OK
now this will take me to
the SQL editor
now this is the SQL workbench so let me
first create a new
SQL query file all right
so first and foremost let me show you
the databases we have for that I'll use
the command so databases
if I hit tab it will autocomplete
I'll give a semicolon
and hit Ctrl enter to run this
there you go here you can see the list
of databases that we already have
and
from the list of databases we are going
to use the SQL underscore IQ database so
to use this database I'll write the
command use
SQL underscore IQ
I'll give a semicolon
I'll select this
and I'll click on this execute button
if I run this
you can see now I'm using SQL underscore
IQ database
now if you want to see all the tables
present in SQL underscore IQ database
we'll use the following command so I'll
write show
tables now this will list all the tables
present inside SQL underscore IQ
database if I run it
you can see here it has executed
successfully and it has given us seven
rows which means we have a total of
seven tables in this database you can
see there's an author table there's a
table called books we have customers
email employee players and weather table
so all these tables we are going to use
in the course of this video
now if you want to
have a look at the data present in one
of the tables you can just use the
select statement so I'll write select
star from let's say I want to see
the data present inside the employee
table so I'll write employee
so this is my table name I give a
semicolon if I select this
hit the execute button there you go
it shows me
that it has returned six rows
and
these are the column names we have the
name of the employee the age of the
employee we have the employees salary
and the employee ID
so there are total six employees in the
table
all right
now I can do the same operations on my
SQL command line as well now let me open
the command line first
okay so this is the MySQL command line
client it is asking me to enter the
password so I'll give my password first
all right now here you can see I have
come inside my sequel now the operations
that we performed on the MySQL workbench
the same operations can be performed on
the command line as well so I'll write
use
SQL underscore IQ
I'll hit enter
you can see the message it says database
changed now if you want to display the
tables present inside this database I
can use
show tables command
I have to give a semicolon and hit enter
there you go you can see the list of
tables we have inside the database
now if you want to have a look at the
content of one of the tables I can just
write select star from let's say players
semicolon hit enter you can see
the rows and columns in the data set all
right
and with that
let's move on to our first question on
SQL
okay
so our question is what is the
difference between where and having
clause in SQL
so where Clause is used to filter the
records based on the specified condition
while the having Clause is used to
filter the records from groups based on
specified conditions you need not worry
we'll do the demo for wherein having
Clause using the employee table
so where Clause cannot have aggregate
functions
such as count sum Min or maximum
having Clause can operate on aggregate
functions
now where Clause is implemented on rows
well having Clauses implemented on
columns now let me show you an example
of how a where Clause is different from
an having clause
so I'll take you to my
MySQL workbench
all right so we are on the SQL workbench
so suppose I want to get the records of
the employees whose age is greater than
for this I can use a where clause
so
since I want to get the employees whose
age is greater than 30 I'll use a where
Clause I'll write my SQL query as select
star
from
employee
where
I'll write age is greater than
30.
if I give a semicolon and run this
it will return all the employees whose
age is greater than 30 you can see 36 36
and 35
these are the employees whose age is
greater than 30
now
I have intentionally kept some
duplicate rows because we are going to
use this in our next questions again I
can also do the same task using the
having Clause so let me just copy this
query
I'll paste it here
now instead of where
I'll write having
so you will see
that even this query will return the
same result if I run it you can see it
gives me the same result
now
let's say I want to find all the records
where the count of age for all the
employees is greater than one in this
case I can't use a where Clause it will
throw me an error since where Clause
cannot be used with aggregate functions
so let's try using an aggregate function
in the wear Clause so I'll write select
star from
employee
where
count of age
is greater than one so the idea is to
find all the records where the count of
age for all the employees is greater
than one
so if I run this SQL query
you can see
it has given me an error it says invalid
use of group function
now instead we need to use a having
Clause along with the group by Clause to
solve the problem
so I'll group all the age values and
then find the count of each age value
so let me just
paste this and here I'll edit my SQL
query instead of where I'll write having
and just after the table name I'll use
the group by clause so I'll write Group
by each
now let's run it
all right you can see our SQL query has
returned only those employees
whose age occurs more than once
now let me just verify this if I
run my employee
table
you can see Angela's age that is 36 has
has been repeated twice you can see
Angela here as well and similarly we
have
Mike also repeated
twice
all right
now let's see the second question
now this is a multiple choice question
where you need to answer the correct SQL
query based on the question
so the question is
the correct SQL query to select all the
records of employees with Ari in the
names is
so we have a list of four options given
and out of that you need to find the
correct option
now
the answer to this question is
this
so if you write select start from the
table name which is employee here where
name like then if you give this
condition it will return
all the records where employees have Ari
in their names
now like is an operator in SQL that is
used to search a specified pattern
so here our pattern is we want all those
employees who have Ari in their names
the first percentage means that the name
can have any number of letters in the
beginning followed by Ari in the middle
and the last percentage means the name
can have any number of letters in the
end so let's do this on our MySQL
workbench let me first display all the
employees in the table so I'll write
select star from
employee
I'll run this
if you see my table
I have one employee who has
Ari in its name
and that person is Karin
I now want to get this particular record
so what I can do is
I'll write a select query select star
from
employee where name
then I'll use the like operator where
name like within double quotes I'll give
percentage Ari
again a percentage close the double
quotes and give a semicolon if I run
this you can see
MySQL Query will return only Carin now
let's do one more example
suppose I want to find the employee
whose name starts with d
so
the way to do is something similar to
what we saw just now
so here in my condition
I'll just
replace this with d this means
the name should start with d
and after that it can contain any number
of letters
now let's run it
there you go so our table had one
employee called Danny whose name started
with d
now moving to our third question
so the question is we want to write a
query to find the players with the least
number of goals
so there are two methods to do it
one where you can use a sub query and
the other method to use the limit
operator so let me show you both the
methods
first let me go ahead and display all
the tables present in my database that
is SQL or SQL underscore IQ
all right if I scroll down you can see
we have a table called players so I'm
going to use the players table to find
the player with the least number of
goals
so
let me show you the first method that is
by using a sub query
so I'll write select
star from my table name which is players
where
goals
equal to
and in this I'll write my sub query
using
brackets so I'll select
minimum goals
from
the table that is players
I'll close the bracket
and then I'll give a semicolon
now let me go ahead and run this
you can see
Matt was the player from Scotland who
scored
the least number of goals that is three
now let's break it down so what we did
was
first
MySQL Query
found out what was the minimum goal
scored by a player so if I run this
you will see it will return me three so
three was the least number of goals
scored by one of the players
now in my outer query
what SQL did was it searched for those
goals
where the value was equal to 3 so we
wrote select star from players where
goals equal to three hence
if I run this
you will find the player whose scored
only three goals
and that player is matte
all right
now the other way to do is using the
limit operator so this is more simpler
than the previous method
I can write select star from players
order by
goals
now let me first run
this SQL statement if I run this
you can see
we have ordered this in ascending order
so the person who has scored the least
number of goals appears
at the top
and the person with the or the player
with the highest number of goals appears
at the bottom and from this table I only
want the first row and for that I can
use the limit operator so if I write
limit 1 it will display only the first
row
if I run it
you can see it shows me only the record
for matte moving ahead now let's see the
fourth question in our list
the question is
write the SQL query to find the player
with the second highest number of goals
now again there are two methods to do it
one is by using limit and offset and the
other method is to use a sub query so
let's see both the methods
I'll first write my SQL query using
limit and offset so
my query will be select star from
players
order by
goals
descending
let me just run this
all right so here you can see
my table has been ordered
in descending order of goals so Anthony
has scored the most number of goals then
comes Daniel followed by Sam and at the
end we have Matt who scored the least
number of goals
now out of this I want the player who
scored the second highest number of
goals which is Daniel so I want my SQL
query to return this row that has player
ID 103 name is Daniel
countries England and goals is 7. for
that MySQL has two features
so I can use
limit one
followed by
offset one
so what
this query does is
it will offset
one row that is it is going to offset
the first row or it is going to skip the
first row and then print only the second
row because I have set my limit to 1. so
let me just run it
you will see
we get the desired result the player
name is Daniel and the number of goals
scored is 7.
now the other method to do is using a
sub query now let me write my sub query
first I'll write my outer query which is
Select star from
and here I'll write my sub query select
star from
players
order by
the column name which is goals
in descending order
here I'll limit it to 2
then I'll give my Alias name as
t
then I'll use
order by
goals
limit
one
let me just run it first
if I run this
you see here I get the same result
now let's first break it down I'm going
to run this sub query first so here I
have select star from players order by
goals
descending and limit is to
let me just run it
so the selected SQL query returns
the first two rows ordered by goals and
if you see here clearly
we have again ordered the value returned
in ascending order which means
from this table
if I order this table in ascending order
Daniel should appear first and out of
that I am limiting my
result to 1 so it will print only Daniel
if I run this again you can see I have
the desired output now let's check the
fifth question in our list
given the below email table write a SQL
query to find the distinct domain names
from the email column so if you consider
this as my email table the domain names
are gmail.com Yahoo dot in and we have
hotmail.com these are the distinct
domain names now to solve this task
again we have two methods either you can
use the substring underscore index
function or you can use the substring
function
now the substring underscore index
function returns a substring of a given
string before a specified number of
delimiters
so let me first use the first method
okay so here on my SQL workbench I'll
write select
I'll use
the keyword that is distant
then I'll use my function which is
substring underscore index
here
substring underscore index will take
three parameters the first is the
original column name which is email
followed by the delimiter I am looking
for that is at the rate so I'll put at
the rate with single code since it is a
text or a character
and then
I'll give the number of times to search
for the delimiter here it is going to be
-1
so you can either give a positive value
or a negative value if it is a positive
number
then this function will return all
to the left of the delimiter if it is a
negative number the function returns all
to the right of the delimiter
all right
and then I'll give an alias name as
say domain name
from my table that is email
if I run this
you can see I have the list of all
unique domain names or distinct domain
names that we saw in our table
this is one of the ways the other way is
to use the substring function
now the substream function extracts the
substring from a string starting at any
position
so let me write my SQL query
I'll write select
distinct
I'll then give my function as substring
here substring will take in two
parameters
the first parameter is the column name
which is email ID here so I'll write
email
I'll give a comma
next
I want to find my delimiter so for that
I am going to use another function
called locate and here I want to locate
the index position of at the rate
so I want to
give my delimiter as at the rate
followed by the column name which is
email
and then
I want to fetch everything after the
delimiter and for that I am giving Plus
1.
again let me give a domain name as the
Alias name
from email
if I run this
you will see we'll get all the unique
domain names Gmail yahoo.in and
hotmail.com
so these were the two ways to solve the
same problem
now moving ahead
let's look at a sixth question
so our question is write the SQL query
to find duplicate records from a table
without using a temporary table now
one of the other variants of this
question is
to delete all the duplicate records from
a table without using a temporary table
now to solve such queries you can use
the group by Andy having clause
let's look at how to do it
so
here on my SQL workbench I'll write my
select query as select
star
and then I want to count all the
duplicate values
let me give it an alias name as
frequency
from
my table name which is employee here
and then I want to group by
name
having
count
star
greater than 1.
let me just run it
all right you can see it has written me
two rows
the name is Angela and Mike and
the frequencies 2 let me just verify
this to see
all the repeated records that were
present in my employee table so I'll
write select star from
employee
if I run this
and scroll down here you can see Angela
is present
here
as well as at the bottom similarly we
have mic present twice in the table and
hence
rsql query
returned only Angela and Mike because
they were repeated twice you can see the
frequency here
so let's now look at our seventh
question
given the below employee table
I want to write a query to find all the
even and odd records from the table
so as you can see there are two ways to
do it one is to use a sub query and
another you can use the mod function so
let me show you both the ways
all right so let me run this SQL query
to see all the values present in the
employee table so if you see the last
column which is the employee ID column
has
all the employee IDs as unique values so
I am going to use this
in my where condition
so
to find out all the even records
I'll write my SQL query something like
this
right select start from
employee which is my table name where
employee ID
then I am going to give my
in operator
and inside the in operator I am going to
write my sub query which is Select
employee ID
from employee
where
employee ID
percentage 2 is equal to zero
this means
wherever my employee ID is divisible by
it will return only those records so let
me just run it
there you go so here we have easily
fetched only the event records from the
table
similarly
if you want to get only the odd records
from the table you can use the mod
function also so I'll write select
star from
employee
where
here I am using the mod function
mod
EMP ID
comma
is not equal to 0 so I'll use the
exclamation mark is equal to 0.
so if I run this it will return only the
odd employee IDs you can see it here so
those were the two ways in which you can
fetch the even and odd records from the
table
now
let's see our eighth question
so here is the question
below is the customer table
write a query to get the first purchase
of each customer
now if you look at the table
there are three customer IDs
one zero one one zero two and one zero
three
now customer one zero one made its first
purchase on 2nd October 2018 which is
this one
and customer 102 made its first purchase
on 5th of October 2018 and since we have
just one record for customer id103 so
this is going to be his or her first
purchase
so I want to return
101 phone 102 tablet and 103 books
to do this
we are going to use an inner join
if you can see I have used an inner join
and I have also used a sub query
let's write this query on my SQL
workbench
okay
so this query is going to be a little
complicated if you have any questions
then please put it in the chat section
we'll be happy to help you
so I'll start with select
I am going to take an alias name as T
Dot I'll write
cast underscore ID
comma
T Dot
purchased at
comma
the next field I am going to select is T
dot item
from
customers
as t
next I am going to write my inner join
and
inside the inner join I'll write my sub
query is going to be select
customer ID
comma
I'm going to take the
minimum value from the purchased at
column which is
my date column
close this I'll give another Alias as
Min underscore
purchased
underscore add
from
my table name is customers
then I am going to group it by 1.
here 1 means
the First Column that you have put in
the select statement which is customer
IDs so I am grouping by customer ID
and close the bracket
and everything
I am going to give an alias name as T1
now I am going to join on
T Dot
customer ID
is equal to
T1 Dot
customer ID
and
my next condition would be T Dot
purchased
at
is equal to
T1 Dot
Min underscore
purchased
underscore
at
I'll give a semicolon
I would request you to go through this
SQL query in a detailed manner so that
you understand it line by line
let me just run it now
if I run it
okay it has thrown me an error which
says table SQL underscore IQ customer
does not exist the reason is my table
name is customers
all right so let me run it once again
okay so there's one more error it says a
known column purchases at so we had made
a spelling mistake here
it should be purchased at now let's try
and run it
all right there you go so for customer
id101
the first purchase was made on 2nd of
October 2018
likewise for customer ID 103 the first
purchase was made on 5th of October
and similarly for customer id102
the first purchase was made on 5th of
October again
now moving to the ninth question
so
here we have a weather table we want to
write an SQL query to find all the date
IDs with higher temperature compared to
its previous dates
so if you see we have a date ID column
we have
the date and the temperature
using this table I want to find those
IDs with higher temperature compared to
its previous dates so if you look for
date ID 1 the temperature is 32
for data id2 the temperature is 31
for data ID3 the temperature is 30.8
now if you clearly notice for date id4
the temperature is 31.5 which is
actually higher than the previous date
ID which is 30.8
similarly for date ID 5
the temperature is 33 which is again
higher than the previous date which is
31.5
now if you look at the date values they
start from 10th of March till 15th of
March 2020.
now to solve this query we are going to
use
SQL joins again and I'm going to use a
function called to underscore days
now my sequel to underscore days
function Returns the number of days
between a given date and year 0. so
let's go ahead and write this SQL query
all right
so first let me select
all the rows from the temperature table
which we are going to use for this
particular question
I'll run it
all right there's some error
actually the name of the table is
weather and not temperature so I'll
write weather
let me run it
okay so here you can see
these are all the rows present in the
weather table and as I explained I want
to return only the date ID for
and this date ID which is 5. now one
thing I want to
make it clear here that this data ID
should actually be six so there was a
mistake while creating the tables please
consider this date ID as 6 and not 5. so
I want to return data id4 and date ID 5.
all right so let me go ahead and
write MySQL Query so I'll write select
I'll write
a DOT
date underscore ID
from
whether
as a
comma
I'll join weather as
B
where
e Dot
temperature
is greater than
B Dot
temperature
and I'll give my condition and
I'll use the function to underscore
days
and give my value e Dot
date underscore well
is equal to
I'll use the function again to
underscore these
B Dot
date underscore
well
plus one
now I would like to know from our
viewers why have we used plus one in the
wear condition so please put your
comments in the chat section
let me just run it
there you go so here you can see
MySQL Query has returned the date ID 4
and 5. which means these are the date
IDs where
the temperature is higher compared to
the previous dates
all right
now coming to the last question on this
interesting session on SQL interview
questions for data scientists
so there are two tables one is the
authors table and the other is the books
table I want to write an SQL query to
find the second highest author who sold
the most number of books
now this is going to be my SQL query
again we are going to use joins on both
tables author and books along with
limit and offset operators so let me
show you how to do it
so first I'm going to join my author
table and The Book Table
so I'll write select
e Dot
author underscore name comma
I'm going to find the
sum of
copies sold from the books table so I am
giving my Alias name as B
Dot
copies underscore sold which is my table
name
I'll give an alias as
sum underscore sold
from
author as a
join
books as B
on
I'll write
B Dot
book underscore name
is equal to
a DOT
book underscore name
I'm using book underscore name as my
criteria because
book underscore name is the common
column to both the tables
then I'll use a group by clause
I'll write Group by
a DOT
author name
then again I'm going to use an order by
Clause I'll write order by
some underscores hold and I am going to
order it in descending order so I'll
write DSC
I'll set my limit as 1.
and
offset S1
if I run this
you will find
that MySQL Query has thrown an error the
reason is we have used
a column called bull underscore name so
it should be book underscore name
there was an error here
let me run it again
okay there was another small error
this should be some underscore sold
let's run it
there you go so my SQL query has
returned author 3
because
author 3 sold the second highest number
of books now let me just remove the last
few lines in the script
let me just run it now
if I run this you can see author one
sold the highest number of books
followed by author 3 who sold the second
highest number of books and then it was
authored 2 who sold the
least number of books
so if I write limit 1 and
offset 1
what this line of code will do is it
will skip the first row and print the
next row
so let's just run it
and you can see it has written me the
author who sold the second highest
number of books if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
in today's session we'll be discussing
some of the top mathematics interview
questions for data science these
questions are based on various topics in
mathematics such as statistics
probability and linear algebra so let's
begin with our first question
the first question we have is what is
normal distribution
now normal distribution is a probability
distribution that is used to check how
your data is distributed
your data could be spread out to the
left or to the right but in many cases
the data tends to be around a central
value with no bias left or right as you
can see on your screens now this is
called a normal distribution where half
of the points are to the left and
another half of the points are to the
right of the center now such a
distribution is contributes to 68
percent of the data falling within one
standard deviation of the mean
then we have 95 percent of the data
Falls within second standard deviation
of the mean so if you add up 13.6
percent
and the 68 percent plus 13.6 percent
this will result to 95 percent of data
falling within two standard deviations
of the mean and finally we have close to
99.7 percent of the data falling within
three standard deviations of the mean
so this is
what a normal distribution is all about
now moving on to the next question
so what are the different measures that
are used to summarize the distribution
now to get more idea about the data and
summarize the distribution
you can use three types of statistical
measures the first we have central
tendency measures then we have variation
measures and finally we have shape
measures
now under central tendency measures we
have mean median and more
now the mean is the most frequently used
measure of central tendency in a data
set let me take you to the Wikipedia
page and explain you what mean exactly
is
okay so here you can see on the
Wikipedia page it has the formula to
calculate the mean of a distribution so
this is basically the summation of all
the data points divided by the total
number of data points so here you can
see an example we want to find the
arithmetic mean of 5 values which are 4
will pick the fourth element from our
ordered set of points that is 6 here and
hence 6 is the median for this ordered
set of points now if you have an even
number of observations as you can see
here total we have eight observations
now the median becomes x n by 2 plus x n
by 2 plus 1 divided by 2.
so your median becomes the mean of the
middle two numbers that is 4 plus 5 by 2
which is 4.5 all right
now the next statistical measure we have
on the central tendency is called the
mode
so the mode is the most frequently
occurring value in a set of data points
so here you can see an example we have a
set of data points six three nine six
six five nine three so your mode is
going to be 6 here since 6 is occurring
Thrice in the set of data points
okay
now under variation measures we have
variance standard deviation and
interquartile range so first look at
what variance is
so variance is the average of the
squared differences from the mean now
this is the formula for variance you can
see x i represents the individual set of
data points and mu represents the
average value so mu is nothing but the
summation of all the data points divided
by the total number of data points so
this is your formula for variance
next we have standard deviation so
standard deviation is a measure of the
amount of variation or dispersion of a
set of values a low standard deviation
suggests that the values tend to be
close to the mean while a high standard
deviation suggests that the values are
very spread out now here you can see the
formula for variance now this is denoted
by Sigma and your standard deviation is
nothing but the square root of variance
so here you can see the formula for
variance you have x i minus
your mu Square which is the mean of all
the data points divided by n
then we have the interquartile range
which is also known as IQR so IQR is a
measure of variability based on dividing
a data set into quartiles so an
interquartile range measures where the
bulk of values lie so the formula for
IQR is Q3 which is the third quartile
minus the first quartile so here you can
see we have a list of data points then
we are ordering the data points first
and then
we cut the list into quarters so first
you have the q1 then you have Q2 and
finally you have Q3 so for these set of
data points
your IQR is going to be 7 minus 4 that
is 3.
then we have shape measures so under
shape measures we have skewness and
kotosis so skewness is a measure of
symmetry your distribution is symmetric
if it looks the same to the left and the
right of a Center Point
now they are majorly of two types one is
called negative skew or which is also
known as left skew then we have positive
skewed or right skewed
and finally we have kurtosis so kurtosis
is a measure of the taitliness of a
probability distribution it defines how
heavily the Tails of a distribution
differ from the Tails of a normal
distribution so if you consider these
distributions the ketosis will calculate
the tailed less which is actually these
areas of a distribution
now let's look at a third question
so the question is create a sparse
Matrix in Python
now in numerical analysis a sparse
Matrix or a sparse array is a matrix in
which most of the elements are zero now
there are multiple ways to create a
sparse Matrix
I'll show you two ways to create a
sparse Matrix so let me take you to my
jupyter notebook where I'll create a
matrix first and then we'll see how to
create sparse Matrix out of it
so I am on my jupyter notebook here
first let me import the necessary
libraries so first I am going to import
numpy as NP and then
from PSI Pi will import
sparse
I'll run this cell okay
next let me go ahead and create a matrix
I'll use the NP dot array function
and within this function I'll create a 3
cross 3 Matrix and I'll assign the
elements
so my first row will have one two three
next we'll have 4 comma 5 comma six
then
we'll have
7 8 and 9.
all right let me run this cell okay
now
let me go ahead and
print my Matrix so I'll use
the print function and
let's say I'll pass in a message that is
original
Matrix
comma and then pass in my variable name
that is Matrix let's run it so here you
can see I have my original Matrix it is
a three cross three Matrix and has nine
elements in it
first let's see how using dictionary of
keys you can create a sparse Matrix so
for that
I'll write the print statement and then
I'm going to use a function which is
called dok that stands for dictionary of
case underscore Matrix
and I'll pass in my variable name which
is my original Matrix so if I run this
you can see
I have got my dictionary of keys sparse
Matrix
next
I'll show you how using diagonal storage
paste you can create a spark
that I am going to use another function
that is sparse dot Dia which stands for
diagonal underscore Matrix
and within this function I'll pass in my
original Matrix variable name
if I run this you can see we have
created diagonal storage based sparse
Matrix all right
now moving to the next question
so given below is a matrix
now we need to find the inverse of this
Matrix
now the inverse of a square Matrix e
which is sometimes called as a
reciprocal Matrix is a matrix a inverse
such that the dot product of a and a
inverse is always I which is an identity
Matrix now in numpy we have a function
which you can see here that is NP dot
Lin ALG dot inv that helps you find the
inverse of a matrix let me show you on
the jupyter notebook
first let me print my original Matrix
all right now here
I'll use the function with Min that is
NP Dot
l i n e l g dot inv which stands for
inverse and then password my variable
name that is Matrix if I run this you
can see I've got the inverse of my
original Matrix
now moving to our fifth question
so this question is related to
probability
you call 2 over X and three lifts if the
time that each takes to reach you is IID
what is the probability that all the
lips arrive first next we want to find
uberX arrive first now this is fairly a
simple question first let's look at
until the lifts arrive first
then first we need to find the
probability that the first car is a lift
which is going to be three by five since
we have three lives and total we have
five
vehicles
next we want to find the probability
that the second car is ellipt which is
going to be 2 by 4
third we need to find the probability
that the third curve is also a lift
which is one by three now the right
first is going to be the multiplication
of the product of
the above three probabilities that is
three by five into two by four into one
by three which is nothing but 1 by 10.
next
let's say you want to find for all the
Ubers that arrive first so you need to
find the probability that the first car
is Uber which is nothing but two by five
since we have two Ubers
next
the probability that the second car is
an Uber is going to be one by four so
the total probability that all the Ubers
arrive first is going to be the product
of two by five
and one by four which is also 1 by 10.
now moving to the sixth question the
mean median and mode of a distribution
are
30 25 and 20
we need to determine if the distribution
plot will be positively skewed or
negatively skewed
so you can see from the distribution
graph the mean is to the right median to
the middle and mode to the left
so since the value of mode is less than
the mean and median the data will be
positively skewed and similarly the
skewness of the distribution is on the
left if the mean value is less than the
median and the mode occurs at the
highest frequency of the distribution
now the next question we have is
what are covariance and correlation
so covariance and correlation are
measures that help you understand the
relationship between two continuous
variables
covariance tells the direction of the
linear relationship between two random
variables
the direction means if the variables are
directly proportional or inversely
proportional to each other
so increasing the value of one variable
might have a positive or A negative
impact on the value of the other
variable
now covariance can take any value
between minus infinity and plus infinity
So Below you can see the formula to
calculate the covariance so you have
summation x i minus X bar X bar or X Dax
here represents the mean x i represents
the individual points then this is
multiplied by y i minus y Dash or the
mean of Y divided by the total number of
observations
next we have correlation so correlation
explains the change in one variable
leads to how much proportion changes in
the second variable correlation tells
how strongly two random variables are
related to each other it takes values
between minus 1 and plus one a negative
correlation means they are inversely
proportional to each other a positive
correlation means they are directly
proportional to each other if the
correlation coefficient is 0 then there
is no linear relationship between the
variables so here below you can see the
formula to calculate the correlation
now moving to the eighth question
so what are the sampling methods used in
data science
now sampling is a statistical technique
that is used to select manipulate and
analyze a subset of data points and find
patterns and Trends in the large dataset
bin examined
now there are two types of sampling
methods
we have probability sampling and
non-probability sampling
now under probability sampling we have
something called as random sampling
so in random sampling every individual
is chosen entirely by chance and each
member of the population has an equal
chance of being selected
then we have stratified sampling so in
stratified sampling subsets of the
population are created based on a common
factor and samples are randomly
collected from each other
now talking about systematic sampling so
in systematic sampling a sample is
created by setting an interval at which
to extract data from the larger
population
an example could be selecting every
fifth row in a spreadsheet of 100 items
and creating a sample size of 20 rows
for analysis
and finally under probability sampling
we have cluster sampling so in a cluster
sampling subgroups of the population are
used as the sampling unit rather than
individuals so the population is divided
into clusters and the whole cluster is
randomly selected to be included in the
analysis
now let's look at the sampling methods
that are present under non-probability
sampling
so first we have convenience sampling so
for convenience sampling the samples are
selected based on the availability so
this method is used when the
availability of samples is rare and
costly
So based on convenience samples are
selected
second we have quota sampling so quota
sampling depends on some preset standard
the proportion of characteristics in
sample should be the same as the
population
next we have purposive sampling
it is also known as judgmental sampling
you select members of sampling on the
basis of the objective of the study
it is very useful when you want to reach
a particular or targeted sample quickly
finally we have snowball sampling so the
snowball sampling technique is used in
situations where the population is
completely unknown and rare now coming
to the ninth question in our list
so explain what P value tells about
statistical significance
so p-value is a statistical test that is
used in hypothesis testing
it helps you to decide whether to accept
or reject the null hypothesis the null
hypothesis represented as h0
is a commonly accepted fact it is the
opposite of alternative hypothesis
researchers and scientists work to
reject or disapprove the null hypothesis
they come up with an alternative
hypothesis that they think explains a
phenomenon and they work to reject the
null hypothesis
for example null hypothesis or h0 could
be the World is Flat and an alternative
hypothesis could be the world is round
so lower the p-value the greater the
statistical significance of the observed
difference
now the p-value is just one piece of
information you can use when deciding if
your null hypothesis is true or not the
p-value lies between 0 and 1 as you can
see here
the threshold for p is set to 0.05 when
the value is below 0.05 the null
hypothesis is rejected
now coming to the final question in our
list of mathematics interview questions
for data science so the question is what
do you understand by type 1 versus type
2 error now in statistical Theory the
eye testicle error is an integral part
of hypothesis testing
in statistical hypothesis testing no
test is ever 100 certain
that's because we rely on probabilities
to experiment
even though hypothesis tests are meant
to be reliable there are two type so
type 1 error occurs when the null
hypothesis is true and we reject it it
is also known as a false positive
finding or conclusion an example could
be an innocent person is convicted
and type 2 error occurs when the null
hypothesis is false and we accept it it
is also known as false negative finding
or conclusion an example could be a
guilty person is not convicted so here
you can see we have a reality where your
null hypothesis is true and here we have
the null hypothesis is false and this is
where the type 1 error lies so
this can also be represented as false
positive where the null hypothesis is
true and be rejected and this could be
false negative where the null hypothesis
is in reality it's false and we accept
it in a previous video we had discussed
the important interview questions on
mathematics statistics probability and
linear algebra that are often asked in
any data science interview
today we will learn about some of the
machine learning and deep learning
interview questions
so let's begin with the first question
the first question is how to detect
outliers in data
so in data analytics and machine
learning
you often find data points that lie at
an abnormal distance from other points
in a random sample from a population
those are called outliers now outliers
in data can significantly impact any
prediction analysis there are majorly
three different methods to treat
outliers
first we have the univariate method
it is one of the simplest methods for
detecting outliers the univariate method
uses box plots a box plot is a graphical
display for describing the distributions
of the data
box plots use the median and the lower
and upper quartiles
this method looks for data points with
extreme values on one variable next we
have the multivariate method so the
multivariate outliers can be found in an
n-dimensional space having n features we
look for unusual combinations of all the
variables in this method finally we have
minkowski error
this method reduces the contribution of
potential outliers in the training
process the minkowski error is a loss
index that is more insensitive to
outliers than the standard mean squared
error now moving on to the second
question
what is a confusion Matrix
so a confusion Matrix is a table that is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the True Values are
already known
the target variable has two values
positive or negative
The Columns represent the actual values
of the target variable which you can see
here the rows represent the predicted
values of the target variable which you
can see here now there are four
important terms that are related to
confusion Matrix first we have true
positive which is this one
so in true positive the predicted value
matches the actual value
so the actual value was positive and the
model also predicted a positive value
then we have true negative
which is also represented as TN the true
negative depicts the predicted value
matches the actual value
now the actual value was negative and
the model predicted a negative value
next we have false positive now false
positive is also known as type 1 error
in false positive the predicted value
was falsely predicted the actual value
was negative but the model predicted a
positive value finally we have false
negative now false negative is also
known as type 2 error
so in false negative the predicted value
was falsely predicted the actual value
was positive but the model predicted a
negative value
now moving to a third question
which is explain the ROC curve
now the ROC curve is one of the most
important evaluation Matrix for checking
the performance of any classification
model
Roc stands for receiver operating
characteristic receiver operating
characteristic or Roc curve is a method
to compare the diagnostic test
The ROC curve is created by plotting the
true positive rate against the false
positive rate at various threshold
settings so here on the y-axis you have
the true positive rate on the x axis we
have the false positive rate the true
positive rate indicates the proportion
of observations that were correctly
predicted to be positive out of all
positive observations similarly the
false positive rate is the proportion of
observations that are incorrectly
predicted to be positive out of all
negative observations
you can take an example suppose in
medical testing the true positive rate
is the rate in which people are
correctly identified to test positive
for the decision question let's say the
coronavirus testing Roc does not depend
on any class distribution this makes it
useful for evaluating classifiers
predicting rare events such as diseases
or disasters now moving to the fourth
question we have
what are the assumptions for linear
regression
so linear regression analysis is used
for modeling the relationship between a
single dependent variable Y and one or
more feature or predictor variables
some of the important assumptions for
linear regression are
so first
they should have linearity so linear
regression needs the relationship
between the independent and the
dependent variables to be linear
it is also crucial to check for outliers
since linear regression is sensitive to
outlier effects next we have homo
sedasticity
homoscedasticity illustrates a situation
in which the error term that is the
noise or random disturbance in the
relationship between the features and
the target variable is the same across
all levels of the dependent variables
third we have Independence so
observations should be independent of
each other
finally we have no multi-collinearity so
there should be little or no
multi-collinearity independent variables
should not be too highly correlated
now moving to our fifth question in our
list of interview questions
the question is what is regularization
in machine learning explain the L2
regularization
so regularization is a machine learning
technique that is used to reduce the
Errors By fitting the function
appropriately on the training set in
order to avoid overfitting of data so
overfitting happens when a model learns
the detail and noise in the training
data to the extent that it negatively
impacts the performance of the model on
new data so here you can see we have
a nice plot which shows how overfitting
of data can be visualized
and here
we have
a good fit line over the same data
points so this is also known as the
regression line
now L2 regularization is also known as
Ridge regression
so Ridge regression modifies the Overton
model by adding the squared magnitude of
coefficient as a penalty term to the
loss function so on the right you can
see a set of data points plotted and we
have our linear regression line
and here we are calculating the cost
function for the ridge regression line
so our cost function is actually loss
plus Lambda into summation of w Square
where loss is actually the sum of
squared errors or squared residuals
Lambda stands for penalty for the errors
W is called the slope of the curve or
line
okay now consider a case
where there are two points passing
through the linear regression line
now if you calculate the cost function
we get the value as 1.69 so here we have
assumed that loss is 0 since the two
points lie directly on the line we have
taken Lambda to B1 and W is 1.3 so if
you use this function or this formula
you get the cost function as 1.69
now moving ahead
let's consider another situation where
we'll calculate the same cost function
for the ridge regression line there is
some loss for both the points as they
are not on the same line so here you can
see the sum of squared residuals is 0.05
is actually is the sum of 0.2 Square I
am assuming this as 0.2 and 0.1 for this
one
so if you square both and add it the
value is 0.05 a Lambda is again 1 and W
we have assumed to be 0.6 now if you
find the cost function the value is 0.41
let's draw the linear regression line
and the rich regression line with all
the points we find that the rich
regression line as the best fit since
its cost function is less if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now coming to the sixth question
what are the different methods to split
a tree in a decision tree algorithm
so there are three methods to split a
decision tree first we have variance
so reduction in variance is an algorithm
that is used for continuous Target
variables
this algorithm uses the standard formula
of variance to choose the best split so
here you can see the standard formula
variance which is summation of X that is
all the individual points minus X bar
which is the mean squared divided by the
total number of observations
now the split with lower variance is
selected as the criteria to split the
population
now the steps to calculate variance is
you need to calculate variance for each
node and then you need to calculate for
each split as the weighted average of
each node variance
moving ahead the second method we have
is Information Gain
so Information Gain is used for
splitting the nodes when the target
variable is categorical
it works on the concept of entropy
now the degree of disorganization in a
system is known as entropy so here you
can see the formula for Information Gain
which is 1 minus entropy
finally we have Genie impurity so Genie
impurity is the probability of
incorrectly classifying a randomly
chosen element in the data set if it
were randomly labeled according to the
class distribution in the data set So
Below you can see the formula for
General impurity
so we have 1 minus summation of p i
whole Square where n represents the
number of classes and po Phi represents
the probability of randomly picking an
element of class I
now moving to the seventh question
so the question is how do we find the
optimum cluster value in k-means
clustering algorithm
now there are two methods to find the
optimum cluster value
so first we have the elbow method which
is one of the most well known for
finding the optimum number of clusters
so in this method you need to calculate
the within cluster sum of squared errors
for different values of K and choose the
k for which within cluster sum of
squared errors first starts to diminish
so in the below plot of squared errors
versus the number of clusters k
you can see at K is equal to 4 the
squared error starts to diminish so
hence our Optimum K value is 4.
next we have the silhouette method
so the siloid method measures how
similar a point is to its own cluster
compared to other clusters
the average siloid method computes the
average celloid of observations for
different values of K the optimum number
of clusters K is the one that maximizes
the average steroid over a range of
possible values for k
the siloid score reaches its Global
maximum at the optimal K so in our case
the average siloid reaches maximum at K
is equal to 2 which you can see here so
our Optimum cluster value will be 2 here
moving ahead
the eighth question in our list is
how does the pooling layer work in a
convolutional neural network
so the pooling layer performs a down
sampling operation in order to reduce
the dimensionality of the feature map
so in the pooling operation you slide a
two dimensional filter over each channel
of feature map and summarize the
features lying within the region covered
by the filter
it is a common practice to periodically
insert a pulling layer in between
successive convolutional layers in a
convolutional neural network
architecture
so the pooling layer operates
independently on every depth slice in
the input and resizes it spatially using
the max operation
so in the diagram shown here you can see
we have a rectified feature map we are
using a 2 cross 2 filter and performing
a Max pooling operation
so consider this as the filter if you
perform the max operation over the
values
let's say 0 5 3 and 1 so considering
this one our pool feature map maximum
value will be 5. similarly for this
chunk of data it is going to be 7 next
if you slide the filter over this square
frame you get eight and similarly here
you get six so this is also known as a
pulled feature map
moving ahead
the ninth question in our list is how
does lstm Network work so long sort to
memory networks are a type of recurrent
neural networks that are capable of
learning order dependence in sequence
prediction problems so remembering
information for long periods of time is
practically their default Behavior
now lstms also have this chain like
structure which you can see here
but the repeating module has a different
structure so instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting in a very special way now
you can see these are called as Gates
these Gates contain sigmoid activations
a sigmoid activation is similar to the
tanage activation instead of squishing
values between -1 and plus one it
squishes values between 0 and 1
and lstm has four Gates
now these are called forget remember
learn and use or output so if you see
this in the first step we use the forget
gate that decides what information
should be thrown away or kept
the information from the previous hidden
State and the information from the
current input is passed through the
sigmoid function values come out between
0 and 1. so if the value is closer to 0
it means you need to forget that
information and if the value is closer
to 1 it means you need to keep that
information
next we have the input gate so the input
gate is used to update the cell State
first we pass the previous hidden State
and the current input into a sigmoid
function
that decides which values will be
updated by transforming the values to B
between 0 and 1 0 means not important
and one means important
you also pass the hidden State and
current input into the tan H function to
flatten the values between -1 and plus
one this helps to regulate the network
then you multiply the tannage output
with the sigmoid output the sigmoid
output will decide which information is
important to keep from the tanh output
and finally in step 3 we have the output
gate this output gate is used to decide
what the next hidden State should be
first we pass the previous hidden State
and the current input into a sigmoid
function then we pass the newly modified
cell State into the tan H function
we then multiply the tan H output with
this sigmoid output to decide what
information the hidden sheet should
carry the output is the hidden State the
new cell State and the new hidden state
is then carried over to the next time
step finally
talking about the last question in our
list of interview questions we have
explain the concept of gradient descent
in deep learning now gradient descent is
an optimization algorithm which is
mainly used to find the minimum of a
function in machine learning gradient
descent is used to update the parameters
in a model
parameters can vary according to the
algorithm such as coefficients in linear
regression and weights in neural
networks
you can see
we have these maps and on the y axis we
have the loss
on the x axis we have the weight
and here we are trying to find the local
minimum or the global minimum
now this gradient descent method is used
to minimize the cost function and update
the parameters of the learning model
the gradient always points in the
direction of the steepest increase in
the loss function
the gradient descent algorithm takes a
step in the direction of the negative
gradient in order to reduce the loss as
quickly as possible
to determine the next point along the
loss function curve the gradient descent
algorithm adds some fraction of the
gradients magnitude to the starting
point now this process is repeated to
find the global minimum
all right with that we have reached the
end of D7 of our data science week I
hope the past seven days were really
interesting and informative that helped
you learn the leading data science
skills if you have any queries please
feel free to put them in the comment
section of the video we'll be happy to
help you thank you all for watching this
live session thanks again and keep
learning